hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to another three scary games
it's gonna start off with a game called
first winter with it which is a
pixelated style horror game set in the
cold depths of winter I think anyway 10%
I don't know what that means I can only
assume it's good know April 16th 1982 ah
whoo ah so very pixelated I can only
assume that's Rambo hello I can't hear
anything
for you to pick up video games Soviet
sub takeover okay computer OOP hi hello
you supposed to do anything for me okay
I guess not I don't even have any
clothes what I did you just move in here
we live in my parents hello
oh no that's the Godfather it just looks
really creepy when it's pixelated like
that looks like the Slender Man if I
wasn't too mistaken but I'm pretty sure
that back to the music right away but I
do have some breaking news this
afternoon coming out of the White House
the US Navy is reporting it's
intercepted a Soviet submarine in the
North Pacific the suspicious vessel was
first spotted around 120 nautical miles
west of Los Angeles a senior United
States Navy officer has described the
nuclear power submersible as being
provocatively closed which does not
sound good and it's currently unknown if
the vessel is equipped with nuclear
weapons the Soviet Minister for Foreign
Affairs has denied any provocation and
insists that the submarine is in
international waters and therefore has
no obligation to abandon its routine
exercises in the area so we'll give you
more on this situation as and when we
get it but now let's get right back into
the music right now on w ng 103.7 okay
that doesn't sound worrisome at all yeah
a nuclear submarine with nukes on it
probably nearby the Los Angeles area why
am I locked in my own apartment
oh okay all right nobody panic this is
perfectly normal power goes out all the
time then all you gotta do is reset the
circuit breaker and everything should be
hunky-dory
I thought I turned that off that's my
door is that my door please tell me
that's not my door I can't use it so I
can only assume that it's not my door
and nobody's watching me in my apartment
should I uh should I do something about
that
everything's totally fine thousand
normal occurrence this is a normal
apartment hallway everything is fine and
happy don't like any of that sound hello
oh it's locked okay are you gonna change
hallway I'll make you better not
something I've got some concerns about
that in particular if you do oh no did I
see it did Presi to pick up I picked up
a cassette tape good I'm gonna shove
that in the first cassette player I can
find it I'm probably not gonna be scared
by the contest they're in does this have
anything to do with feet hmm does this
have anything to do with the UM okay
there's nothing in this one
it seems familiar I played a lot of
horror games but I think I played this
one before what he'd a minute I mama
wait
hey let me go look at my channel okay
wait a God let me look this up first
winter it seems so familiar this seems
this seems so familiar but yet wait a
minute wait but hang on it's like an
updated version or something cuz I don't
remember that intro sequence at all but
now I'm maybe I gonna yeah we'd hang
your knee yeah but it's not on my
channel where did I play this what did I
do
oh hi yeah no wait there is nothing
intrinsically wrong with being in a
location of your actions in that place
cause no harm or intimidation a problem
may occur on the other hand if one is
considered a threat whilst occupying
such a facility
the mother will risk her life to chase
away anything should she receive a risk
to her car
[Music]
I'm gonna I've look I'm my mind is being
blown right now because I'm almost sure
maybe it wasn't called first winter
maybe that's the thing of it cuz I kinda
remember that survival under atomic
attack because I remember the door
mechanic and but I don't remember the
opening sequence I think this is just an
updated version of the game and there's
something else do this if I open it's
gonna be a different room in here yeah
yeah I think this is just an updated
version of the game if there's a room
with a bunch of beds with a bunch of
bodies underneath like covered by
blankets then I am for certain gonna be
able to okay I don't remember that at
all oh okay this ain't uh must have been
a oh I don't remember that at all
it must have been an early demo oh hey
okay that's not what I was thinking of
when I said body under a blanket
[Music]
hi hello oh [ __ ] hi hey you all right
buddy Fred how are you doing okay if
that's Morse code I'm not really paying
attention right now wind it up wind it
the water turned to blood
[Music]
okay well alright first e to use Morse
code okay I know that that's Morse code
over in the access code and I gotta oh
you need to get through hang on here you
go hello my name is Mark bar okay
goodbye
alright so I need to remember the code
so I can type it in the thing that's
easy enough that was t I i-i-i-t which
stands for Ted no was it not oh it's oh
okay it was hot it was it was not tit it
was tat
oh oh so the last one was uh uh uh uh w
w ta aw okay so his tau I thought it was
dead and then I thought it was tapped
huh gah loose lips mines
you want to know about my loose lips my
lips are the loosest the lousiest
juiciest lips you've ever seen okay all
right I gotta close ago oh never mind I
don't gotta close the door I distinctly
I distinctly remember playing a game
that was much like this and it must have
been just the demo the room I told you I
read with the room there's gonna be
bodies what's this
to retreat and say phase especially in
the theatres of war has been a
perplexity as old as conflict itself
the child may well tidy his rope but not
directly after a dressing-down
hmm left to his own devices will allow
him to decide the himself or at least
appear to lose it okay alright are you
talking about Warren you comparing war
to disciplining a child who's that
[ __ ] that seems like a pretty big
thing to do
Wham what's locked whoa whoa whoa whoa
okay oh boy Oh mr. Boddy's what did I
tell you guys I told you it was the
Berardi's Oh totally bribed oh it's
barricaded I couldn't couldn't tell
maybe for good reason considering you up
I know come fuh oh no that ain't gonna
come for angle wait wait a tick wait
at-at where did Teddy weddy hear nothing
some matic on her ability room if I'm
not mistaken jumped ins something
appears to be holding it shut
Hey whoa but hey lose your strength as
you die of exhaustion holding this thing
shot or did you run away because you
knew I was coming
whoo nice hole okay it's okay bad
combination safe use keyboard numbers to
unlock up I don't know no numbers so I'm
gonna just look around for Sumi it's
locked
[Music]
didn't mean no good okay all right
anybody know where I could find some
numbers anybody know where maybe some
numbers are booby okay that's a lady in
a bikini
all right I don't think there's anything
numbers to be gained from though you
picked up a locker key
Oh the only lock blocker well that's
gonna do me some good
I unlocked a locker Oh fake-out picked
it up a cassette player but oh sure a
cassette player in one of these oh hello
I can't read this captain your 474
nautical miles off course
proceed immediately to your assigned
mission location failure to comply will
result in severe consequences
okay um oh I don't really know how that
helps me I got accept but I don't know
where
Oh oh no I thought that was the thing so
what's with the big earth show Oh
shattering kaboom right if the
subordinate shows disobedience then
naturally he will need to be disciplined
any Maya subordinates rash decision
however it's even more important you
should never allow the other side to
suspect mutiny if the viability of the
product is compromised then the
reputation of the corporation will
surely balan comparing corporations to
pirates
you said mutiny no with huh there's a
lot of [ __ ] going on here wait this
is the ending of the demo before whoo hi
oh hey oh whoa
hi okay hope I scared you as much as you
scared me willow all right look
[Music]
you learned your lassen like you
hahahaha
close the door on you alright definitely
not behind me
definitely not oh my face why would you
shoot my face what's behind door number
one whoo-hoo nothing okay
alright what are you doing to me was mom
door number two okay no was behind door
number three I got a bullet hole in my
face but I don't get it
alright what if I sound seem to be what
if I walk backwards did that do it
backwards here seem to be a whole lot of
nothing going on here alright well okay
alright luck
well Leningrad blew up I'm sorry about
that London it's blown explody New York
oh no oh that's bad Moscow
not Los Angeles you should turn or maybe
not maybe maybe maybe that's for the
best
okay all right well I'd like to think
I'm directly responsible role what oh
that's right take some of my explody
vision okay all right then
going here now you have a lovely day
hello sir how you doing Fred okay okar
I like car cars real nice how do i how
do I open the code did I already fail
that well I never be given another
opportunity to open up the code
I like codes codes are cool or hello
okay right then
excuse me I need to look up more more
pictures of oh yes all right okay that's
where I came from it's kind of like a
grid I think if it's like a grid then
maybe it's not like a grid at all where
am I going and why for that matter
okay long I'm gonna Solway that never
ends okay all right I don't like this
okay all right I'm beginning to think
I'm being fooled here I'm starting to
conundrum eight that there may not be an
end to this whole way but I'm a
persistent son of a [ __ ] Atari oh [ __ ]
please subscribe subscribe that like
button I'm going on tour and Amsterdam
in July not you gosh oh we're gonna be
Australian a stalemate is the situation
in which further action or progress by
opposing parties seems impossible the
deadlock cannot be broken for fear of
one side or the other losing everything
and gaining nothing the knot can be
loosened however if both sides become
better informed of the other party's
situation more often than not there
neither side will want to show their
hand before the other and thus the
stalemate continued
[Music]
okay all right sure
oh never mind forget about the Bell
no one needs to know about the Bell just
gonna make my way out of here oh hi okay
all right cool I understand by I'm very
busy I can't sign any part of oh thank
you take that oh thank you
great thank you so helpful goodbye
forever peekaboo okay all right
hello how are you how are you oh boy
that's okay all right yeah all right
cool I did that oh that goes down but do
I want to go down nice horn okay it's
locked where's the key there's a wheel I
got I got a wheel nice we don't need
music I just want to mention that
straight up we don't need it doesn't
need to happen
I like silence is the foe here's the
thing all right well good I guess
still nothing in here okay still nothing
all right well I don't know the code to
that so oh hey how's your hair buddy
really he shot me
hey listen list friend hey come on give
me your thumb
give me your thumb cut it off give it
hand it through a slot let's just lumps
too big in which case I won't promise I
won't judge you from your giant thumb
I'll go downstairs I guess maybe over
this way I can't go down there for some
reason you're too far away to hate it
no I hate her done her good I hate it
more didn't think I could
hey Fred I didn't think I couldn't hate
it more but I hate it more shockingly no
baby alright okay hello baby are you
okay alright Fred how you doing uh-huh
yup yep
okay all right there was no point in
coming down here just spend some time
with the dead here
I'll be on my way
well somebody supposed to go some 300
valve I have that I had a wheel I don't
know what that's doing
but it's real Gergely and I like that
everyone knows I've got a particular
penchant for the gurgly did that like
lower the water level in here
oh it raised it why did we do that now I
don't see the bodies anymore
hey little baby all right good I guess
that's real nice I suppose so
so what about that huh y-you go boom
y-you go a baggie oh I got a empty
bottle wait no it wasn't empty at all
zero three six zero got it zero three
six zero vows handy sorry everybody down
there that I flooded zero three six zero
got it
okey-dokey then your three six zero whoo
I got a key for a locker this seems like
a roundabout way just to open up a
locker there we go Oh weenie meanie
miney moe
ah I got it I can't have both oh well
guess I just gotta chop off ooh they
know I'm coming knock knock here's
Freddie hello
what that's unfortunate don't know why
but okay periscope up okay
well oh I get it
oh he'll on oh no he launched Oh No
target acquired and validated he
launched and then killed himself
why oh man
okay well this is a problem Oh one
minutes ago okay uh boop beep
1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 got it ooh oh that's ok
um well damn hard boy I don't know if
there was like some oh okay well Oh
missile inbound let's uh see I guess
[Music]
I was in an apartment in the beginning
this I was in an apartment oh oh okay
all right
whoa hey how's it going there 60 seconds
to go
the gravity of the situation was
underestimated like a western gunfight
one party it would seem has drawn first
the bullet however takes 12 minutes to
reach the cowboy giving both sides ample
opportunity to empty their barrels oh
[Music]
that's not good but accurate I guys but
oh ho ho I don't know if there was like
a code that could have shown up or
something these are white why can I pick
up every single one of these they're
like a hidden code in this that I could
have could have had you know kept
probably early not okay oh no let me
just look at all my possessions where's
my porn there there you are baby
that's a playboy oh boy okay well I
guess I'll duck and cover then it's
gonna go to bed okay all right well
locked in here no no
hello wait a minute
okay I'd like to leave now
whoo okay hey my name is Mari blur good
you ring that Bell all right you know
what I I don't think it's a good idea to
do oh I can leave okay good okay I'm
dead I'm dead
that's a boom that's a good movie that's
a big kaboom all right well ah that's so
cool yeah the reason it was like ringing
ending the first nuclear winter so there
was it was away there was a way to get
to the other ending I don't know what
that was though
where was the other
anything how do you get to the other end
Dania that's so cool all right but I'll
leave it to you guys because I got other
games I need to play but this was cool
it's so cool to see this game go from a
demo I don't remember what the name of
the original game or the demo was but
this was really cool good job Dan but we
got to move on because we've got more
games for you alright so in the same
vein as the Dora the Explorer horror
game I think this is made by the same
person or team for all I know but this
is night I think this is Nightmare on
Elm Street if I don't know wait wait no
it wasn't Nightmare on Elm Street was
steamvr get out of here
I gotta play this game of your nightmare
on Sesame Street dois odo II love the
ready is dead I need to find another to
wake up am I not awake already
find another radio to wake up alright
okay alright so um so um you're uh
you're a Freddy Krueger out there but uh
gonna come get me hi
oh that's probably bad that's probably
very tough I can't open it okay well I
can't open those which is concerning
because I were always closing the
apartment doors is the only way to
escape Freddie okay so I need so I need
to find a radio also what does it mean
by closing the apartment door do I have
to go back to the first building and
close the door to escape Freddie also
where is Freddie whoa those yeah that's
pretty loud kaboom ease I didn't mean to
do that okay anyway elmo's got a cape
going I guess let's go throw maybe dig
through the trash
why okay
hello ooh another apartment close okay
any of these open can I steal someone's
radio oh that bad okay all right that
doesn't make any sense
hello hello hello can I leave this
hellhole no apparently not can I go to
this way no normally not can I go into a
flower shop can't close the door and
another radio to wake up okay I got it
Oscar you in there no response guess I'm
all alone whimper uh-huh okay much once
I'm literally just running into him and
I'm not even opening the mouth so I'm
just an idiot the hell was that
whoo hi oh hi hello oh there's a radio
oh oh no that wasn't enough to wake me
up I need to find another radio wait
he was just he was just here oh why is
he over there okay I don't know I don't
know I don't know I don't understand
Oh one two buckle my shoe three four
knock at the door five six pick up
sticks seven eight lay them straight
nine ten a big fat hen
okay all right that's not quite what I
recall from the Freddy thing no no still
wasn't enough maybe one more radio will
wake me up okay why why do you need what
why all right whatever
clunk thunk cool hello Big Bird big bird
big bird me Barney they're big Big Bird
big bird Big Bird big bird ABC one two
three baby girl okay maybe it respawned
in some other area that I've been to
already I have no idea oh no no too fast
no no no I need to get to a door that
closed oh now I'm down no no snippy
please I don't I got two radios bad oh
this is not gonna be pretty
Oh
okay let's oh [ __ ] oh no it's oh no it's
gonna be like the Kurds the Cowardly Dog
game I'm just gonna die over and over
again okay but at least I know where
they are unless Iran would care rated
which is always a possibility oh there
it is got it okay all right one wasn't
enough this is make sure so it could be
anywhere I guess which is not very
helpful but I'll take it I suppose and
I'm only assuming that it spawns one
after the other in random locations
throughout this entire map on my beer
while always coming in as much no oh
yeah no no no no no oh no no I didn't
know that there were things there
Oh in here oh I didn't know that it
could be in here okay I only need one
more radio which is good
[Music]
okay well that that dis way used him let
me just check upstairs just in case of
one by my bed or something good ha ha ha
yes okay Oh was that it would was that
was that it was I did I win oh I seven
seemed like winning a mono like
[Music]
Oh what the hell a cinematic what Oh
oh no Elmo doesn't like this dream oh no
it's more than one dream oh no Elmo come
on oh come on oh what has he done to you
that's not good okay so um what's my
objective besides running away from him
I don't want to the steam events really
want to get me it's too bad for them I'm
just too damn good and handsome at this
game hi but no no no no no no get in the
bed get in the bed all right okay I
don't know how I could have gotten
around you all right take do we got this
see if you'll sneak that way
[Music]
around the corner oh this is gonna be
tough and in the dark he shouldn't be
able to see me maybe go back just left
whatever I'm going for that looks like
an exit don't turn around
badge is perfect to could sleep great
exactly what is oh uh oh that's a cookie
arm yeah I guess Oh
wakey-wakey ah it's either noon or
midnight and I don't know which one's
better
oh wait never mind hi you skate Freddy's
ever
[Music]
oh I see oh I see you over there okay so
that was nightmare on Sesame Street
as usual the middle silly game in the in
the cavalcade of games of horror but
this next one should definitely scare
the patooties off of you actually this
might be made by the same exact person
but I don't know yep same guy okay all
right let's see what this one is this
one's a highly rated one that's not
relating to any other oh I don't know
what that means but okay alright welcome
to strange terror from beyond the stars
made by the same guy that made the last
game actually so I don't know if it's
gonna be silly I don't know if it's
gonna be like thoroughly scary but all I
know is that we're ready to go monster
the monsters we dealing with Oh
[Music]
okay all right let's do this
I don't know I don't know what this game
is about I've gotten I know an X nothing
about this game hmm you sure you want to
go out there it's pretty dangerous man
once you step out that door I can't let
you back in here I don't have a choice
I'm not gonna wait any longer I mean
they're gonna find a way out of here or
I'm gonna kill that thing that's out
there
All Right see yourself just wait here
till help arrives whoa okay well what if
I don't actually nothing I think about
guys we got a lot of real food here all
right well that's cool probably copy
written but that's okay
loses say I still can't friggin believe
how it snuck on board the ship
apparently it crawled in through the
external exhaust that it left open
allowing and easy access on to our ship
well then that seems pretty easy to
believe why can't you friggin believe
that that seems like a very apparent
thing to believe hello okay all right
okay goodbye
mwah mwah love you All Right see ya I'm
off to my death Oh captain
gotta find the key card eh oh oh so it's
like oh it's like a oh it's randomly
John rooted with monsters I like that I
like that so it's like every time I play
this game it's a different monster so
they all have different behaviors well
come and get me mr. monster man someone
complains of smooth jazz no one there
thank you
the door malfunctioned and now I'm stuck
in the groom
am I getting me out all right oh okay
all right
I don't know Howard oh oh okay it's a
fly I've got deal with the fly all right
well now I've gotten multiple things
that I got to deal with know what that
is who's doodling who's doodling okay
I've got the armory key card but I gotta
get to the armory first that fly thing
just went that way
armory is this apparently this is to the
armory Hey
but that means I can get a gun and I can
kill it oh don't forget to smile laugh
and have a great day
what did I open oh hi
okay where's the armory wanted Claudia
bear I don't know if that means that's a
reference to something but I have no
idea
hello oh this is spooky
we found a wrench okay I might be able
to pry that guy's thing open all right
who can there mom I'm gonna go back the
way I came
wanted it Dave microwave for breaking
the fourth wall reward a microwave I
don't know what these are but they're
awfully duty
what did that do oh alright okay
armory let's do this open oh that oh oh
that doesn't help what the hell I got a
screwdriver I don't know what that means
that looks bad I probably shouldn't try
to go through that I need a fire
extinguisher all right where the hell am
I gonna find a fire extinguisher I know
what those do they make it impossible
for me to hear if that things coming
also my big blabbering mouth does the
same job how I hello I got a wrench cuz
the help you're welcome
yes I don't like that scooter what I
think he dropped something
I don't know if I want to go get it bomb
doing it
steam maintenance key wait uh I remember
there being a steam maintenance area I
just saw it it's quiet
okay got it steam maintenance steam
Minuten yo
so where's some steam mutiny new okay
that's weird alright let's just spin
this
that did it I guess
Oh another one got it I fixed the steam
I really maintained it that's just stop
the pipes from emitting any more fire
yeah okay
so now I can go the armory get a gun
let's just go for let's just let's just
go for it and see what happens cuz if I
can get a gun then I can kill this thing
right the rescue sure [ __ ] ain't gonna
happen so I might as well make it happen
myself is that space that's beautiful
but I don't have time to look I gotta go
all right what else we got
don't tell me there's another key card
that I got to deal with god oh I can use
this to kill the monster but it only has
one round better make it count okay all
right
oh this is a lot of pressure that you
just put on on me I don't like that I
don't like the pressure you think that
we would have more than one gun on this
spaceship yeah maybe not actually
shooting guns in space might not be the
best idea
all right come on monster where you rat
ha it's fly you show your ass here I
don't have two big plates with wish to
squish you so you're gonna have to get
in front of my bullets and let them do
this crucian for me by losing my
patience
mr. Floyd I don't like this seems like a
bad place to try to encounter this fly
man 3 dude where's my targeting reticle
and I got you oh that's the end of that
yes yes
goddamn goddamn man I'm such a badass
I'm such a god you and your friends
survived except that one guy that one
guy got I got n dick three of five good
oh oh you could oh you could have
multiple and not only are there multiple
monsters but there's multiple game
endings game endings oh that's so cool
what did I even kill I'll fly man oh
yeah well that's so cool so they
probably behaved in relatively similar
ways but maybe they have some
individuality so that's really cool so
if you guys want to play a game that's
randomized with a horrible monstrosity
z' and multiple ways to beat it check
out strange terror from beyond the storm
so thank you everybody so much for
watching this has been three scary games
I hope you enjoyed them if you got more
ideas for scary games that you want me
to play write them down in the comments
below and you can check out all these
games through the links in the
description below also everybody in
Amsterdam we're gonna be coming to you
me and all my friends are coming back
for Amsterdam for the show that we
missed you can check out the tickets at
toor dhal markiplier calm and if you're
in Australia and or New Zealand check
out tour Dom markiplier calm for us to
see you in November thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know what
you thought down in the comments as well
and as always see you in the next video
[Music]